je vais tout faire pour me sentir
j'ai pas confiance
tu dis que tu as fait une crise d'asthme
sévère tu peux et du respect
je me joindrai
je fasse disparaît cette voiture
j'espère que tu sais ce que tu fais
on va tous y passer alors c'est moi qui
vais m'occuper s'en va j'ai pas médias
ce qui se passe
tu a renversé maturité cette fille d'un
baron de la drogue que j'ai envoyé en
prison
ce crime ne peut pas rester impuni
si la prendre c'est toi qui a renversé
son fils tu seras plus jamais en
sécurité nulle part
donc ils remontent jusqu'à lui il aura
fait disparaître les preuves
pour attirer l'attention coupé on est
tous dans la justice pour servir quelque
chose dans le trophée lave l'honneur de
la famille en cause par lui
dans quelle merde tu nous a foutu
[Musique]